these con is starting to ban images of
women in bikinis you'll be in public
signage he's bringing in Sharia law
good-hearted people good Christians Jews
whoever's out there they see through
this there you have it you heard it
straight from his mouth there is only
one Islam you know then I looked at his
response
I cannot connect the dots I cannot
understand his rationale you know we
gave to him with evidence that there is
only one Islam sensationalism selective
statistics and selective news reports
but that's a fact that you have far more
every think about it than to hear what
Christians do that every single day in
this country do they blow people up yes
all of the Christians every day people
walk into post off I mean people walk
into post offices they walk into schools
that's what Columbine is I mean I could
do this all day long there's so there
are so many more examples of Christians
and I happen to be a Christian that's
back to this notion of you're idealizing
Christianity in my mind to my read
there's so many more examples a yawn of
Christians who do that and you could
ever give me examples of Muslims we've
done it inside this country where you
live work that even if the enemy kills
all of the innocent Muslims or civilians
even then Islam does not give them the
right to even touch harm or kill
innocent people from the enemy sighs
want to really get technical you look at
the Lord's Prayer you know everyone
knows that who's a Christian o our
Father we would say our Lord right who
art in heaven hallowed be thy name thy
kingdom come thy will be done
so submitting to the will of God right
that's Islam it speaks about peace and
justice and what he did was he just took
that term Islam and he said okay that
one Islam is radical Islam it doesn't
make sense the Christian group it's a
Christian God obviously they don't
represent mainstream Christianity but
you're making is this connecting this
the same way he's trying to take this
fringe you know element Isis then trying
to pump them up as if they're
representing Islam after justify
violence by some Muslims but to
understand violence by some Muslims you
know according to the
drone missile operators they have done
the interview so in News Channel than
the interview of them two of them and
they said the drone missile operators
they said that ninety-five percent our
intended targets we miss it so we are
fasting because Jesus and Moses and
Abraham and Noah peace be upon all of
them they also used to fast dedicating
their lives to the service of the
Creator the heavens are the same creator
that created Jesus the one that Jesus
pray to call people to worship - the
Creator we're worshiping the one God
worship Him alone not his creation we
got a very special guest in the studio